-You had a 50th birthday party
in June.
-I did.
Thanks for rubbing it in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-And then you had --
-Are you anywhere near 50?
-I'm getting there, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I'm about --
yeah, I'm 44, so, yeah.
-Okay. Oh, no.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, anyway, thank you.
-What about -- you had a show --
Did you have a show
the night of or no?
-No, we -- My staff surprised me
with a birthday show,
and I was, you know,
if you're a talk show host,
you are used to
being celebrated and stuff
and you're comfortable with it,
frankly.
-Yeah.
-But, man, I was on my way
to my show,
and it was my "surprise"
birthday show.
And I was like -- I was bashful
for the first time in my life.
And then I got there.
I thought Anderson Cooper was
going to walk out,
but John Mayer wound up walking
out and hosting my show for me.
-That's very exciting.
-It was incredible.
-And was Dolly Parton there
as well?
-Dolly called in.
She was the surprise caller.
-That's fantastic. That's great.
-It was awesome.
-So you had
a very good birthday.
-Yes, I did. It was awesome.
Yeah.
-You mentioned Anderson. You
guys are going on tour again.
-Yeah, we're still on tour.
We've got Vegas, Philly,
D.C., L.A., this fall.
-Wait, is it called
"An Intimate Evening"?
-Very intimate.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's like going to the bar
with the two of us
and hearing our greatest
stories.
We were just in Charlotte
a few weeks ago.
-And you have added to
your greatest stories
while this is happening.
You got in an -- you were
traveling together as you would.
-Yes.
-You got in an altercation
at the airport.
-Oh, I did on his behalf
kind of.
-On his behalf?
-I was basically,
we were at LaGuardia
and I was organizing --
-LaGuardia is where celebrities
fly out of.
-Yes, exactly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like a --
It's a private airport.
-It's all private, yeah, yeah.
It was just he and I,
and I was doing my thing,
which was organizing the bins
as they come out of the --
-Oh, I love that do you that.
-Yeah, no, I totally do that.
[ Laughter ]
Again, it's a celebrity thing.
-Yeah, it's like the bins.
-You guys wouldn't know.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm organizing the bins.
And this woman with a thick
Russian accent said to me,
"I wish you were as diligent
about your reporting
as you are with those bins."
And I said -- She clearly had
seen Anderson two people away
and thought that I was him
because of the gray hair,
whatever.
And I said, "Excuse me?"
I said, "My reporting is
stellar," you know.
[ Laughter ]
And she said, "No, it's not.
You lie and this --"
I said, "What are you
speaking of?"
And I go, "First of all,
you're thinking it's him.
Second of all, he works
very hard to deliver the facts,"
and I went in on her.
And she was with her husband.
It turned into me saying,
"How dare you? How dare you?"
[ Laughter ]
Screaming at her.
Anderson was mortified.
Yes. A nice Russian couple. Yes.
-I just love --
-Screaming "fake news" at me.
-Did they scream "fake news"
at you?
-Yes, yes!
-That's -- I mean -- I have
watched "Real Housewives."
There is nothing fake about
those people.
-Nothing!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They are the realest
representation.
-Yes. Yes.
It's true.
-That is really fantastic.
-Anderson was really mortified.
-You mortified another
news person recently.
-Yes.
-What would you call this?
So, you, like, news-bombed
a woman who was doing --
-I did. I news-bombed a lady
from WCBS here in New York.
She was doing a stand-up
in front of my gym.
And I was like, I gotta -- I was
like, "Oh, my God, she's on TV."
I was like, "Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
Like, I'm on TV every night.
-Yeah.
-But I got so excited that
this lady was on TV.
-This really speaks to
your sense of ego
that you thought you saw.
-I know.
-You were like, "Ooh, a little
extra daytime hype."
-Yeah, yeah.
I was like, "I'm not on WCBS.
I'm on Fox. I'm on Bravo."
Yeah.
-Well, here's a little -- 'cause
she was very angry.
But I will say she was
very excited to see you.
-She came around.
-Let's take a look.
-Caught and arrested last night.
Taken into federal custody
this afternoon.
Law enforcement sources
are still searching for
that third accomplice.
Oh, it's Andy Cohen!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's so -- We made up.
We made up.
And then somehow, I don't know
if she posted it and then I --
I called Anderson actually.
I go, "You'll never believe
what I just --"
He was so pissed at me.
-Yeah.
-It was very upsetting.
I was like, "It was funny
and she liked it in the end."